on a suivi ça en direct au cours de la
nuit c'était à 2h50 très exactement ce
pain sec ce qui est plus que jamais tout
près la d'envoyer des êtres humains dans
l'espace la capsule qui va permettre à
cette campagne de réaliser des vols
spatiaux habités à décoller comme vous
le voyez très très tôt à ce matin en
floride
on va parler avec renault va nourrir à
gagner bons journaux auxquels vous avez
suivi sa également oui effectivement
2h50 j'ai peut-être bouki au professeur
qui a pas écouté le décollage c'est vrai
qu'il y avait beaucoup de monde quand
même qu'ils regardaient donc lancement
de cette capsule qui avait à bord pour
l'instant seulement un mannequin
effectivement dr ce qui ce qui est parti
ce matin pour dire si une version
modifiée d'une capsule que là que spacek
sont déjà utilisé plusieurs fois qu'on
appelle la capsule dragon ou ceux ci le
véhicule qu'on retrouve au sommet d'une
fusée et qui va se décrocher une fois
dans l'espace pour par exemple aller
ravitailler la station spatiale
internationale
mais ce véhicule là est différent des
autres qui ont été conçus pour
transporter des êtres humains et vu
qu'on est plus fragile qu'une caisse de
matériel mais il ya quand même quelques
modifications qui on doit être fait
donc c'est une capsule qui plus grosse
que les précédentes qui contient par
exemple des panneaux de commande ou des
sièges pour jusqu'à quatre astronautes
l'aca possède aussi des systèmes de
survie donc pour s'assurer qu'elles
bonne pression une bonne température ont
un bon niveau d'oxygène à l'intérieur et
cette capsule est aussi équipé d'un
système d'éjection encore d'urgence
gmail a eu des problèmes avec la fusée
pour que les astronautes plus haut à
elle être éjecté en sécurité oui et
cette fusée là comme tous les autres du
space x
elle est réutilisable donc elle est que
la capacité supposée par elle-même et de
re décoller des retraites avait décollé
par la suite parce qu'il faut le dire le
bus et d'éventuellement d'amener des
astronautes américains dans l'espace
dans la station spatiale internationale
c'est exactement ce dont tu le laisse là
c'est exactement ce qui va arriver donc
le test qui avait aujourd'hui vol la
capsule vous justement aller vers la
station spatiale internationale
demain avance ammar et par elle-même à
la station et même si c'est un test dont
1 contient quand même 200 kg de matériel
mais à l'intérieur il ya aussi un
passage et donc il ya ce mannequin qui a
été nommé
plaidons casas en clin d'oeil au
personnage principal de la série de
films éolienne et le mannequin est
rempli de capteurs ces capteurs vont
permettre aux ingénieurs de savoir
justement quelles vont être les stress
qui vont être vécue par les astronautes
une fois qu'ils vont être dans la
capsule et pour être certain que tout va
bien que tout va bien au cours de la
mission
donc la capsule vont rester jusqu'à la
station spatiale euros jusqu'au 8 mars
et ensuite à vous décrocher
elles vont revenir sur terre a déployé
ses parachutes et finir éventuellement
quelque part dans l'océan atlantique et
à ce moment l'aspect sexe aura une heure
pour aller récupérer la capsule donc se
délaisse aussi une exigence de la nasa
parce qu'il faut rappeler que toute
cette mission là c'est comme un gros
examen pour spacex pour l'agent spatiale
américaine
tous les éléments de la mission doivent
remplir ces critères et ses barèmes pour
que cette capsule pause pour un problème
risque pour ses astronautes à elle qu'on
va venir le temps de décoller et pour la
station spatiale internationale
donc beaucoup de futurs contrats de la
nasa qui départ que pour space x qui
vont dépendre de cette mission là parce
que dans le fond la nasa et exigeant
parce qu'elle va vraiment dépendre d'une
compagnie privée mais n'en avait
possiblement spacek celle des lendemains
oui c'est sûr ces citoyens exactement
mais ils ont quand même un plan de
secours mais faut quand même rappeler
que les états unis sont parues le même
le sont cloués au sol en ce moment
depuis la fin du programme des navettes
en 2011 ils ont pu de véhiculer le
véhicule spatial donc le seul pays qui
est en mesure d'envoyer des astronautes
dans la station spatiale internationale
c'est la russie et une facture 75
millions de dollars par astronaute qui
montrent à leur fusée soyouz
donc en attendant le prochain vaisseau
de la nasa qui va prendre du temps mais
là ils se sont tournés vers des
compagnies privées
ceci un mandat qui allait donner aspect
sexe mais aussi à la compagnie boeing
qui prépare sa capsule storyline heures
pour un test comme aujourd'hui mais au
mois d'avril et il s'est un peu les deux
les deux compagnies sont plus en train
de se faire une course pour être les
premiers à en huit ans à envoyer des
astronautes à partir du sol américain
ces longues années après sa belle là
c'est tout va bien le vol
le premier vol vraiment habitée de
spacek va se passer au mois de juillet
il ya deux astronautes de la nasa qui
vont monter à bord et à ce moment là si
tout fonctionne baisse est la cemac la
nasa va décider si elle donne ça permet
à ces a certifié la compagnie perd lui
permet de faire des vols ensuite
faisait la nasa gros en ce moment parce
que l son contrat avec l'agencé spatiale
russe se termine au mois de novembre
donc si spacek ou boeing n'ont pas
réussi à envoyer des astronautes dans
l'espace d'ici là mais les états unis
pourraient se retrouver exclue de la
station spatiale internationale donc je
pense que pose aussi le masque est
nerveux ce matin en regardant la
progression de sa mission c'est clair
qu'il ya beaucoup d'angoissé
merci beaucoup ça fait plaisir c'est
bien